hi guys I'm Eric Voss and rogue one to
Star Wars stories and theaters now and I
can say that it's a totally thrilling
chapter to the Star Wars saga the studio
took a bit of a gamble by making this
anthology prequel with barely any
characters who exist in the other Star
Wars movies but it really paid off and
one of the reasons was all the cool
little ways that the storyline connects
to the original Star Wars Episode for a
new hope and how it filled out the main
timeline of the Star Wars Canon now I'm
about to spoil the image of this movie
and even though I'd say that everyone
has a general idea of how this chapter
the story ends since the very opening
crawl like 40 years ago just they steal
the Death Star plans this movie is all
about how exactly all that goes down and
I'm gonna talk about it so go watch ro
Guan dummy
so with rogue one director Gareth
Edwards wanted it to end with that same
sense of urgency and chaos that begins a
new hope so that one chapter flows right
into the other the result was that the
final act of rogue one moves extremely
fast the pacing is intentionally
disorienting so that we only focus on
the task at hand securing the Death Star
plans it actually feels like a game of
capture the flag or football with the
rebels scrambling to get this MacGuffin
of the Death Star plans across their
lines in to lay his hands so that the
next chapter the story can begin and
it's natural if this all left you with
any confusion or questions but don't
worry because the film actually plots
little moments that set up how this all
unfolds so I'm gonna run through and
quickly explain the chronology of the
updated Star Wars timeline so right as
the final act of rogue one begins we see
gen or so in the gang going rogue and
heading off to scare off' but then we
get this short conversation between Mon
Mothma and Bail Organa two senators in
the Galactic Senate and underground
political leaders of the Rebel Alliance
both of them conclude that war is
inevitable and Organa decides to return
to Alderaan to prepare his people then
they decide to recruit obi-wan Kenobi
who fought alongside Organa and the
clone wars to join their side of the
upcoming war against the Empire Organa
says that he'll send someone who he
trusts with his life referring of course
to his foster daughter Princess Leia and
then remember in a new hope Leia's cover
story is that she was on a diplomatic
mission to Alderaan mmm
of the Imperial Senate on a diplomatic
mission to Alderaan now it's obviously
bogus but that diplomatic mission was
how she initially joined this part of
the story so even though we don't see it
in rogue one it seems like Leia is with
Bail Organa at the rebel base on Yavin
for for this meeting with the Alliance
and then he assigns her to go on the
separate diplomatic mission to find
obi-wan Kenobi and bring him to Alderaan
now Organa knows that obi-wan has a
history with Leia from when she was a
baby and that history may make him
listen to her
but then the plan changes after the ro
Guang crew successfully infiltrates
scare off' to steal the Death Star plans
word about this gets to Mon Mothma
and she says she needs to speak with
Admiral Radice who she learns has
returned to a ship to join the fight and
I think that the purpose of this moment
is to imply that Mothma is altering the
plans for Leia to send her along with
Radice so that if the rogue one crews
somehow succeeds Leia can sneak away
with the Death Star plans under the
guise of her diplomatic mission so then
later in the battle Tarkin arrives in
the Death Star and destroys the Skara
face hoping to also destroy any record
of the Death Star's plans and
vulnerabilities but of course he's too
late
gen was able to upload the plans to the
rebel flag ship after Radice destroyed
the shield and then the rebels
downloaded it onto this glorified floppy
disk because this is Star Wars and
everything's analog and charming so shut
up
and then as Radice orders the rebel
fleet to retreat Vader arrives and wipes
out a ton of their ships he disables the
flagship and boards it beginning this
super tense scene with fader just
stacking up these rebel foot soldiers
like rag dolls do stack rag dolls
does anyone have rag dolls but the
rebels succeed and managed to scramble
the plans to Leia on the tan - for as
Vader watches and prepares to give chase
really dovetailing rogue one with the
daring chase sequence and shootout that
opens a new hope and I just love how
Gareth Edwards directed these closing
shots to show the fear in these rebels
faces it's is that they're looking at
the devil himself and it gives so much
context to why these guys friends are so
afraid at the beginning of a new hope
and really rogue one contextualizes and
clears up a lot of things about Star
Wars that fans have been wondering about
for years first example why was the
Death Star so easy to destroy like how
could a simple proton torpedo fired into
an
exhaust port caused a chain reaction and
bring down this state-of-the-art battle
station well now we know that Galen or
so design that flaw intentionally as a
nephew to the Empire giving the plants
bile drive the specific name of Stardust
which was the nickname he gave his
daughter just to make sure that she
could find them and get them to the
rebels also why is Darth Vader so
suspicious of Princess Leia when she
says I'm a member of the Imperial Senate
on a diplomatic mission to Alderaan well
you just saw her 10:00 to 4:00 leave a
freaking rebel flag ship in the middle
of a battle so really the question is
girl who you trying to fool and then why
is Leia turning to obi-wan Kenobi who's
a hermit on an outer rim planet that she
probably has no memory of as her only
hope help me obi-wan Kenobi you're my
only ow well now this makes a lot more
sense
her father assigned her to go on this
mission to recruit one of the last Jedi
to join them in the Civil War then now
that she has these Death Star plans Leia
can't return to Alderaan because that
would implicate him and she can't return
to Gavan for because that would expose
the location of the rebel base so
obi-wan literally is her only hope and
then people have always wondered why
doesn't the world of Star Wars have a
way to transmit important data without
having to hide a disk drive inside a
droid so other than Star Wars coming out
before the internet was really a thing
k2s Oh actually has a line that explains
this it's the size of the data files
that's the problem the file with the
Death Star plans is just too large the
only way they could transmit it was by
patching this massive antenna on the
Scarab surface and then using that
signal to send it to the rebel ship
above the planet so apparently in Star
Wars file size is as much of a problem
to them as it is to us when we haven't
like updated our phones in a while and
we try to download everything at once
and then why are there a couple
inconsistencies between a new hope and
the other parts of the Star Wars canon
so for example rogue one features a
separate blue squadron of ex wings which
doesn't show up in the Battle of Yavin
in a new hope we also see characters
like death troopers and Shore troopers
and we get a quick glimpse of the ghost
from Star Wars rebels well the final
moments of rogue one clear this up all
of these things were on scare if when
the Death Star wiped out the base so if
they didn't get taken down in the battle
they definitely would have been caught
in the blast so that's why in the Death
Star trench run on a new hope we only
see the remaining y-wings from the gold
squadron and the x-wings from the red
squadron
meanwhile the blue squad
was trapped on Skerritt and finally robe
one also contextualizes Tarkan's
behavior in a new hope remember he was
kind of a dick to the senior imperial
officers should I have your ship
standing by evacuate in our moment of
triumph I think you overestimate their
chances and now it makes a bit more
sense after replacing Critic as
commander of the Death Star this is just
the new guy in charge taking command of
the room so really zine rogue one shed
light on all these things was just super
satisfying it's fun to see the time line
come together like this kind of like
watching characters in a period war film
that we know the outcome of react to the
events and make decisions in real time
alright thanks for watching and check
out the other video I did on the amazing
CGI that they used to create the awesome
cameos of Tarkin and Leia
also I'm planning a longer super
in-depth breakdown of all the Easter
eggs and references to the Star Wars
universe and rogue one like I feel like
I'm definitely enough to watch this
movie a few more times to find them all
but I will do it because I believe in
myself I am one with the force and the
force is with me I'm one with the force
of the forces with me now this video is
brought to you by our good friends at
loot crate loot crate is monthly
subscription box service that hooks you
up with a bunch of cool gear from all
the nerdy stuff that we cover on this
channel and including stuff like Star
Wars and you can sign up right now by
going to Luke rate comm slash rock stars
too so each month has a theme and I just
got this loot crate gaming box from last
month so let's take a look
and you can get next month's box by
signing up by the 27th of every month by
9:00 p.m. Pacific it's less than $20 a
month and if you use our promo code
rockstars you'll get 10% off and we here
at new rock stars are doing a bonus
giveaway where you'll have a chance to
win that gaming box that I just opened
plus a cool giveaway that we gave the
previous lucky winners just go to Luke
rate right now at Luke rate calm slash
rock stars - and tweet at us to let us
know that you did that as well as what
you liked most about rogue one okay
thanks for watching and let me know what
you think about rogue one in the
comments and please hit like and
subscribe to new rockstars and share
this video with your friends also you
may want to double check that you're
getting email notifications on our
videos by clicking that Bell icon
YouTube's been a bit weird about that
lately you can also contribute to us on
patreon thanks so much to all of our
current donors you guys are amazing and
if you aren't currently a patron we
would love your support you can hit me
up on twitter at EI vos with any
thoughts you have on star wars or rogue
one you can also follow new rockstars on
twitter at new rock stars alright thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
Oh